hey take a look at this from uh USGS the
U.S Geological Survey
acid rain uh and then one of the things
that was in the let's let's uh what are
we looking for uh here we go
hydrogen chloride which converts to
hydrochloric acid well that's strange
this says uh
acid deposition commonly called acid
rain is a term applied to all forms of
atmospheric atmospheric deposition of
acidic substances rain snow fog acidic
dry particulates aerosols and acid
forming gases water in the atmosphere
reacts with certain atmospheric gases to
become acidic for example water reacts
with carbon dioxide in the atmosphere to
produce a solution with a pH of about
5.6 gases that produce acids in the
presence of water in the atmosphere
include carbon dioxide
oxides of sulfur and nitrogen and
hydrogen chloride which converts to
hydrochloric acid and they're saying
there's no risk we burned it all off and
you're good to go don't even worry about
it